thank you to Skillshare for sponsoring
this video The Clash of giant men and
monsters is a powerful image that has
appeared in many religion mythology and
folktale throughout the ancient world
and it's a concept that in our secular
modern world continues to live on in a
somewhat different form the mo del
Toro's Pacific Rim is one of those
manifestations and although it very
consciously embraces the silliness of
the genre it nonetheless manages to
transcend the cliche by hinting at its
very deep symbolic patterns of society
and the individual of how a world or a
center can come both to be destroyed and
reborn on the edge or the rim of the
world
[Music]
to begin with the story gives us a
mythological version of the modern world
deep in the Pacific Ocean appears a riff
to a dark dimension of giant monsters
who erupt out of the water as out of
primordial chaos the fact that the rift
manifests in the Pacific Ocean is not
arbitrary because according to how we
have mapped and organized the world even
though the world is a globe it is
nonetheless there in the Pacific Ocean
that the rim of the world is located
where East becomes West where time jumps
from one day to another her rift in
space imaged as the gate of Hades out of
which chaos and death erupts and so
following the analogy the edge the rim
of the world in terms of space is also
where appears the possible end of the
world as cataclysmic destruction of all
civilization that was a preview of this
month's movie interpretation Pacific Rim
which I did in collaboration with Thomas
from the storytellers channel it's worth
going to check out their channel to see
the full video but also to see their
other videos they have a lot of
interesting movie interpretations many
of them using some pretty powerful
symbolic structures as well based on on
Jordan Peterson's interpretations and my
interpretation so it's worth checking
that out for those of you near South
Carolina this week on Thursday March
15th at 7 p.m. I will be at Furman
University in Greenville South Carolina
and I'll be giving a talk there called
zombies vs. icons art monsters and the
apocalypse I did not choose this title
but it'll be an expanded version of the
zombies talk that I gave last year and
so if you're near there it would be
great to meet you so hopefully I'll see
you there and enjoy the Pacific Rim
video this month next month will
probably be the matrix